we have to go to through crazy things in
2020 or whenever we shot that 2019
to be naked on tv with another person
yeah men and women both
he and i needed to sit together with a
sensitivity trainer and talk about like
how our parts were going to be covered
so they wouldn't be touching and then
they come in with
they have a thing called are you ready
for this they have a thing called a
vajoga
which is a yoga mat cut into the shape
of like
a bikini bottom that you put in between
your legs
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we have a very
special guest
we have the illustrious i don't even
know what illustrious means i just use
the word i don't even know what it means
we have the beautiful talented funny
hilarious
jackie tone one of my co-hosts in the
show the best leftovers
ever jackie tone is in the house
everybody yeah yeah
baby baby i'm so happy to be here uh
mostly just because of friendship but
wait i get to just kick it with david
for like an
hour yeah what's up you know what's so
funny like you know what we went into
the uh
the chem test stuff right oh my god tell
the people at home
what a chem test is now so basically a
chem test well first of all
basically you you're walking into it's
kind of like an audition
but you're basically seeing chemistry
between you and other cast members to
see how
it's like next level audition like with
a chemistry test
you don't chem tests unless you're in
the running they don't confess every
person you know the
time so okay go on i didn't know what i
was going in for
you know i just walked in i was like
what do you mean like you didn't even
know it was a cooking show
no i didn't know it was a chem test i
thought i was having a general meeting
with like magical elves
who's i mean not that it matters to
throw anyone under the bus but
does your people just not tell you or
did you not read it you know like what
happened
no my manager told me i just don't
listen so like
i walked in he was like this is a chem
test i'm like what
all right but also we should tell we
should tell your listeners
um i'm pretty sure you came straight
from was it kickboxing what do you do
muay thai kickboxing
i came from like a kickboxing class and
i was like he was like
sweaty in like in like workout shorts
and a t-shirt
and he was like oh i think you even told
me we were sitting in the waiting room
we were like
fully getting along great and i was like
i love this guy and you were like yo i
didn't even
did you know at that point that i was
already hired and i was the host and i
was who you am testing with
i knew nothing like you knew that
because you leaned over to me
maybe thinking i was also auditioning
and you were like yo i did not know what
i was coming to today
and in my brain i was like oh he doesn't
know that the person he's chem testing
with is me
yeah i had no clue i was just walking in
i'm like well let's see what happens
i think you know like my manager's like
yo do you [ __ ] listen to anything
that i said
but you know what that's like some
office space energy is it ron livingston
is that the guy like what's that
character's name and
oh yeah i know you're talking about yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think it's ron
livingston
yeah that's like that guy energy where
like you
walk in and you're so chill and cool
and not desperate that like that energy
is like
wait this has happened multiple times
like when i when i first started
auditioning
um so i i did this film and it got me a
bunch of like general meetings with a
bunch of casting directors
and in these general meetings uh i
remember i met up with the casting
director
afterwards like we just happened to to
walk by each other and she was like
you know it was very refreshing meeting
you during our general meeting i was
like what do you mean she goes well you
kind of just showed up and flip-flops
and socks and
uh basketball shorts and a t-shirt i'm
like well what was i supposed to wear
they're like well you know general memes
are very casual but that's the most
casual i've ever seen anybody watching
you know what's interesting is that can
that can work for you and it can work
against you because i did a series
years and years ago so weird called
regular joe it was my very first
gig i think i was 23 and this nightmare
of a business
somebody wrote this guy david laid who
created king of queens he wrote the
pilot
and then uh they initially they shot the
pilot and it was like a massive family
judd hirsch and daniel stern
and the point of the show was that this
guy joe at the center of it daniel stern
he had like this massive extended family
they all lived in his house just a wild
family show
and then they picked up the show but
they decided it should just be a
four-person family
it should be father grandfather son and
daughter i tried out
and i got the part and guess who else
had to try out against me
the girl they were replacing they were
making her
retry out for her own role
wow and then i beat her out and
then i got fired
and she re-replaced me with her
what kind of mind [ __ ] is that well
anyway the reason i was telling you that
my [ __ ] ass story
was because when i went to like the
table read
i thought that it was cool like i put on
like a little
sweatsuit and i didn't look like shitty
it wasn't you know i was a crazy person
and socks and flip-flops and basketball
shorts and a jersey
i'm
yeah yeah never go to like that
spaghettio david slow level
spaghetti sauce that's me but
i was in like a little matching
sweatsuit and they called my agent and
they were like
this is a table read in front of the
studio and the network
and doesn't she know that she's supposed
to dress the part
and they roasted me for and they were
like it's just a really green move
she's just really green and at the time
i was friends with
name droppy but this is the story i was
best friends with jessica biel and i
lived with her
oh really yes and so she was on seventh
heaven
and so she would she would wear she
would look like a homeless girl going to
work
she would be like she would whatever she
slept in and obviously when it got to
glow and you once you have the job
yeah you show up to work in your pajamas
but really all i knew of like what
cool actors did show up to work
was like look casual like look like you
don't care so i did that
and they were like she's an amateur she
looked awful
and then whoa me and ultimately i got
fired i don't think i got fired just
because of that but it was a big
contributing factor
that's crazy because i damn i don't even
think about that stuff like i just kind
of
in my mind i'm like i'm trying to be as
comfortable as possible
so like if i'm comfortable in this and
i'm meeting somebody then this is the
personality that you're going to get
like i'm not trying to make a statement
or a point but this is just generally
how i look
i also hate to make a flag waving i
don't hate to
i'm gonna make a waving feminist
statement
men can show up in whatever they want
and women have to look
hot young and have perky tits forever
and it's just what it is we need to be
like thin and attractive
and dress nice and have our makeup
perfectly done
in case anyone sees us ever and men when
they show up in basketball shorts my
ex-boyfriend actually who i'm still
close with
he he's very big on that oh rick who you
guys might talk
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna be on this podcast next week
he's oh god are you gonna have fun but
um
anyway uh shout out take your shoes off
pod but
he um he's that way like he doesn't put
on anything other than socks and shower
slides and basketball shorts
and it's kind of his thing and like you
get it and
that's that's what it is like men men do
that stuff and
it's like really cool kind of when they
do yeah i kind of noticed that too
yeah especially like in in the acting
world you see a lot of these like uh
these male actors who later on they find
a lot of success in their career which
you don't see a lot for female actors
past like the age of 40. like for
example like idris elba right he's
killed it when he got way older but i
don't see that a lot for a few years
it's common and
also men societally like
even as a woman like when i was in my
20s like men in their
40s were were hot to me because
society it's like it's allowed where
like
i don't know that except for the
exception of jlo and halle berry and
like jennifer aniston
well they don't age they they definitely
eat placenta of children every day 100
100 sacrificial children but they
with the exception of very few women
it's like
it's not it's it's just not the way it
is i mean there's there it feels like
there's an expiration date
on not it feels like there is an
expiration date on women in our industry
and i think
for me why
something that i am sort of proud of and
wasn't really my choice i was never the
injunu i was never the like
uh i was never the the gorge you know
like the girl that was like the hot girl
in the high school or the hot girl in
the college or the hot girl in the
workplace like that was never
because of what i look like and sound
like for better or for worse
i just was never cast as that but
because of that
as i get older my value hopefully isn't
decreasing
because it's not all hung up on how hot
and perky my tits are
it's hung up on hopefully my
mouth and brain my black open mouth
hear that industry you know so when um
i actually didn't watch so if you guys
don't know jackie is
which i'm so [ __ ] pissed there's not
there was no wrap
up to [ __ ] glow so can't even get
don't even get me started
i binged glow throughout when we were
shooting
because you told me about it because i
i've had it on my list and i'm like you
know what
i met jackie i have to watch glow now so
i got hooked on glow
and then lo and behold where the [ __ ] is
the last season
like it it ended on a [ __ ]
cliffhanger i'm sitting there like
yo what the [ __ ] is going on no it's
it's truly
it's truly it's hard during a pandemic
i mean i have so much like success guilt
and all this weird psychological stuff
wrapped up
so i find it so hard to complain about
glow
not complain because i mean my emotions
are real and yeah i'm allowed to
my we i respect everybody's reality but
it's so hard for me in a pandemic when
there's like dudes walking down my
street um collecting bottles and i'm
running the house i'm like hey man i
have these bottles
and also this hoodie and then tell my
boyfriend hey i just gave your hoodie to
this
dude that walked by i hope that's okay
he's like what the [ __ ]
i really like that i was like sorry that
guy really needed a hoodie
um but also the point of that is just to
say like
in these hard times where people don't
know if they're gonna like put the money
the tiny amount of money they're making
toward their rent or
feeding their children it's hard to be
uh it's hard to i think just i i want to
at least
say that in conjunction with how
devastated i am about glow while also
realizing i'm like
well you're in luck like i think if i
didn't have
that truly if i didn't have our show i
don't even know
the depression i would be in about globe
because i'll be honest you were saying
we were just talking about women having
an expiration date i've been acting
since i was nine
and i got i got glow when i was 36.
you know what's so so cool about that
though like
in years of people being like no not you
see this is what's so interesting too i
think when i was talking to you you're
also mentioning about this
this perception of being like very
grateful for the opportunities that you
have
and um like we were talking about how
there are like certain actors too who've
been doing it for
five six years and they're like you know
what this industry is so tough it's like
five six you just started child
like you literally just started girl i
can't even like i
am an empath of that to the highest
degree and i
no part of me can feel for you right now
and i should i mean honestly i should
everybody's journey is their own and and
also if it's really
if this isn't for you i talk about it
with my boyfriend all the time because
he's a brilliant writer
and he just he it's more important like
stability he's got a great job
and he's got stability and he bought a
how you know what i mean like
he went that road and that's a beautiful
road too
yeah you know i mean there's parts of
him that were like well damn i sort of
wish
i was a beatnik [ __ ] writer just
doing my thing
but the flip side of that is the beatnik
writers doing their thing that i know
are in their 40s in their studio
apartments
off virgil just being like how am i
gonna put beans on the table
so it's it's hard yeah i mean for you
specifically because you started since
you were nine like
how do you like mentally stay motivated
to continually do something like that
right because it's
it's hard for me to to describe to
somebody what it is to do something in
this realm
and not always expect success right
because not only not expect success
get get next to guarantee failure
yeah two percent of the screen actors
guild is working at any one time
yeah 98 of the ones of us lucky enough
to have gotten into the union which is
next to impossible to do our work
it's just you can't even wrap your brain
around it's interesting um
i just recently i should look for this
text and then i do want to go back to
glow because
yeah for sure off on a tangent about not
being able to be sad about glow because
other people have it worse than me
um but i do want to read you this really
quick
um here it is
so i was just up for this probably the
biggest movie of my career
um directed by one superstar starring in
other superstars only five people in the
movie and i was up to be the sister
and it was huge and the massive director
is like sending me specific notes like
he's not giving overall notes he's
calling casting and being like hey
jackie give these notes to jackie right
and it's like it's looking like it's
going to be me
and it's really exciting they're looking
for a long island girl that's obviously
me
very hard to fake that as you can tell
after 25 minutes
not sound like this i still [ __ ]
sound like this so
anyways i'm like ready to go casting
director texts me like yo
are you sure you're available february
to
february to april to do this in maine
she's personally texting my cell phone
i'm like
calling my parents which i never do
because i want to get their hopes up and
i'm like
i made three separate tapes sent them in
the massive directors giving me personal
notes
radio silence after that i find out from
my agent it's between me and this other
girl
who's way more famous than me more radio
silence
game over doesn't happen jesus it's
crazy but that's
i mean that's just what this is so
that's just a microcosmic example and i
think for both of us and anyone in this
business
if you're lucky enough to even get to
that level it's so hard
it's that situations are heartbreaking
but
that i mean the stories like that have
happened to me
i mean hurry hundreds of times
yeah when that happened i said i was
texting my best friend i said i'm
[ __ ] gutted
and she said i know man and i said woof
this business has made me a master of
getting over heartbreak quickly
i'm a [ __ ] professor of
disappointment mitigation at this point
right like you just go like i had a
writing session to do that afternoon and
i was like
practically crumbled in a ball like this
life-changing
opportunity is here after glow got
canceled after i don't know what my next
acting job is going to be i don't know
what anything is going to be and i this
thing is
in my hands and then it's gone and then
my writing partner's like hey ready to
work and you're like
ready and then next that's the hard part
yeah
do a uh an audition and you gotta just
show up the next day because if you
don't show up the next day
you'll definitely not get that one yeah
you know what and
and i think that's like this
conversation is so refreshing because
there's
you know i've i've had a few
conversations with personal friends who
you know they watch a film they get
inspired and they want to go into the
entertainment industry and
they want to do acting and i'm not one
to tell somebody like
hey you don't have it right but what i
want to tell them is that
do you understand what acting entails
you know
it's not just oh i go in maybe i get the
part i don't
and i think like like it's it's and
sometimes when i have these
conversations they feel like i'm
[ __ ] on them it's like no i don't
want to set you up for something
in this dreamland world where you think
that you're going to be successful at
something when like you said
two percent are acting in the union like
that's how [ __ ] low the probability
is
and if you are willing to and the
probability is actually much lower than
that because
your friend probably if i had to guess
is not in the union
your friend is one of those people who
probably doesn't even have an agent yet
doesn't even need that so it's like
you're that guy's not even in the two
percent
exactly and like so like i've had a
couple of conversations with somebody um
who
you know watched the film and they got
really inspired and they said i have
something to offer that other people
don't i was like well hold on a second
like let me ask you this i was like so
i have other active friends who have
been taking acting classes right has
been taking auditioning classes been
acting for 10 years
and you somebody who has never acted in
their life you're going to come onto the
scene and take every role from them when
you haven't done
anything at all and i've and i've seen
you try to act you [ __ ] suck
you know well this is how i am you know
i got to let them know it's like you
like you you [ __ ] suck you know this
right and then
so and the other part that they didn't
really think about this specific friend
has a family right and i'm like you have
a family
you also have a husband did you even
have a conversation with your husband
that you want to go into acting do you
know how much time it's going to take
and how much that's going to entail
like what about your children did you
did you think about this
you know crazy is my mom had to pretty
much give up her life because i was a
kid actor
oh wow even if you're a person who's not
even an actor but you're taking your kid
around like that
i mean it's insanely time consuming i
remember when i used to get a commercial
which would be rare um a friend like uh
a friend who wasn't in the business
would be like well that must be now you
know you make like
let's say 20 grand on a commercial right
if you're lucky
and then um and your friend will be like
that must be nice you just sit home and
the checks come in the mail when the
commercial's on jesus and you're like
well you understand that that 20 grand
needs to last me a hot 12 months because
i've done
zero other jobs and also might i add
cut that 20 grand minus agent minus
manager minus taxes
now we're at about 11. and then you want
to cut from there
the fact that i went on a hundred other
auditions and spent thousands of dollars
in gas money and hair and makeup and
clothes
got none of those i'm still in the hole
and then you have people being like oh
man it must be nice to sit home and have
checks come in the mail and you're like
what do you think this
is charles that's that was the hard part
too when i was like
when when they you know friends from
back home they would say things like oh
you've made it like
made what like what
because all i've made is an omelette and
a maybe a grilled cheese
i was like you know especially because
like in the youtube world like money was
really good at a certain point
right and then um but there's also this
thing too especially like with
podcasting right like people don't
understand it's like you don't have to
pay for the office that i'm in
like you know i have to do all these
like there's like you're the one with
the house
you're the one with the career your life
is a lot more stable than mine dude
and that's the thing too that they don't
get where it's like
that is the trade right like and i have
i have so many friends in new york who
are actors grow up with me
kid actors growing up and they just hung
it up and now they
you know they're teachers or they're
they're doing wonderful things they've
got
gorgeous houses in upstate new york
or in beautiful parts of jersey and
you know they've got their family and
their kids and those are all things
i want desperately you they also want
what i'm currently currently
experiencing desperately
but it's it is not easy i mean you got
to pick one of those paths
yeah especially as a woman you know you
gotta if you want to have kids you
you have to carve that choice
out of that many many year-long choice
out of
you know uh your work schedule if you're
lucky enough to ever have a work
schedule yeah
well for you like you know i've actually
never asked somebody this because
i don't think i've already met very much
like uh child actors like what's
what is that like being a child actor
just because like i see so many stories
about
uh child actors kind of go off on the
deep end and
you know that world seems to be a very
stressful world for somebody at such a
young age
so what's that like for you well
you know i don't think i realize well
speaking of my being the professor of
the disappointment mitigation i mean
that started at age
11 when i booked a rice krispies
commercial which was like my
very first gig uh and
it came out on tv and i
wasn't in the commercial oh [ __ ]
yeah so that was age 11 of just like
and then my parents were really sad for
me
and so by 11 i was taking care of
everyone else
i was going like no no it's fine i was
like making jokes about how i didn't
care
then i would like go in my room and cry
and my parents didn't ask that of me
i could have cried in front of them and
they would have rubbed my back but it
was sort of my instinct to be like no no
like it's cool it's cool like
we got this and then i get emotional can
you see me
yeah and i you know and it was like so
since i'm 11 years since i was 11 years
old i
have sort of been like no no it's cool
like we'll just move on on to the next
one
and having a like it's not easy it
really it really formed
who i am it also made me [ __ ] strong
um and tough and funny
um you know uh and my mom is sickly
funny like real funny
joan rivers vibe funny uh and so like
she never did anything with it you know
she's you know a mom and both my parents
were gym teachers like
super chill upbringing i mean your
parents we i met them
you know while we were shooting this
show you know what the moment that
cracked me up the most
it's like you left the room for a second
to get like a hot drink
and then your mom starts telling
holocaust stories to us
it's just like right before we're about
to shoot and we have to have like this
upbeat mood
i'm listening to him how did that come
up she never does that
listening to so this is like the most
devastating story your mom is telling us
right i don't know how this conversation
came up and
did rosemary bring something up maybe
maybe they had like old people connect
and they were talking about some
struggles but
your mom told this very specific story i
think it was either about
it was about her siblings or her cousins
or something but it was like did it
pertain to leftovers
what it had to do with [ __ ] my mind
so she told me this story
where she's uh talking about um how they
were they had to like shave potatoes or
something like
oh yeah shaved potatoes down but because
they weren't given enough food
either her brother or one of her cousins
her aunt cut out a pocket in her pants
and had to stitch something where they
could hold a potato and would drop it
off to somebody else so they could have
something to eat
she was 10. her aunt was 10. my mom was
born yeah
my aunt was brilliant and so she
was hired in one of the concentration
camps to peel the potatoes for the
soldiers
and since she was a little kid they
weren't they didn't think well she's
nobody to worry about
she cut and sewn clothes
cut and sewed clothes pockets in her
little i mean could you even call them
pants and her
garbage yeah trash clothes
and she would save the potatoes and then
when she would walk back
through the housing should you excuse
the expression at the camp
she would drop a potato out toward one
of her other family members so they
wouldn't die
that's [ __ ] nuts and i was hearing
all these stories i remember
i mean the stories are incredible and
inspiring
and heartbreaking but i cannot imagine
yeah mom was telling you then before we
had to
it's like hey we're about to go on set
keep the energy up well let me tell you
this holocaust story i was like
oh david we need you in 30 seconds have
you heard of adolf hitler
let me tell you about this [ __ ]
ma ma sit down
ma could you please sit down david has
to go out and tell joe well
my aunt was so poor and so starving ma
sit down please i guess she's telling
the story
because i feel like i have to i have to
sit her down and like wrench the stories
out of her and her mother
who actually survived the holocaust the
woman who the potato
sir um my grandma adella she never told
a story to us about it in her life
oh wow one time never brought it up one
time ever
that it's so crazy because like hearing
that too i'm like
i wonder if those type of stories passed
down too
is probably the reason why you have such
like an optimistic outlook right
and i always tell people too that's
super important to understand where you
came from to see where you're going
and those type of stories too even
though it was you know i was damn near
to tears listening like damn near tears
listening to the story
right before i'm about to go on set you
know it was it was so
interesting because i never grew up
around jewish people right i only know
about like asian plaid and you know
our personal immigrant story but when
you hear about something like that it's
it's so it's so intense and when i see
your mom
who's number one a great storyteller and
she's very optimistic super funny
it's like being able to take that and
then kind of compartmentalize or doing
whatever you have with it
to be this very optimistic person to
grow up in this country to raise a
beautiful child it's like
it's it's so refreshing to listen to
thanks
yeah it's powerful stuff i mean i
definitely i come
from fighters that's for sure um
but this is a perfect tie-in uh back to
glo because you were saying like you
know more about the asian plight and
um so the girl that plays my best friend
on glow is named ellen wong
i don't know you were saying you saw
season three and then you were
devastated because you're like and now
there's no more glow
yeah episode where we go camping and
i make the passover seder um
she says i make everything about me and
we're talking and it's jenny and melrose
have this fight
um and then we start talking about
inherited trauma
and it comes out that melrose is such a
wise ass
because she's really covering up all the
pain
from her childhood because
she melrose is in the 80s is the
daughter of holocaust survivors and
she's sort of telling this story to
everyone like
you guys think i'm this [ __ ] clown
and you guys but did it ever occur to
you that like
i have to laugh and make jokes so i
don't think about the fact that my dad
can't live
in a house without an attic or a
basement so in case they try to come and
kill us we have to hide again
yeah and it's intense and then jenny che
ellen's character
starts talking about well we have that
in common because
we escaped the cambodian genocide and we
came here
on a marine plane we came to the united
states on a marine plane
full of rice where they smuggled us and
everyone
we knew was slaughtered and me
and my mom and my dad were the only ones
that got away
and that's a true story from her actual
life
that's [ __ ] crazy that's so nice
that so me and ellen these two women
from the most different walks of life
the most different ethnicities the most
different personalities
the most different looking we're sitting
here
connecting on inherited trauma and
where our families came from and being
survivors
and it's just glow
i mean how powerful for a
show to take the truth of the women
playing the characters
and infuse it into the show to be
immortalized or memorialized forever
yeah i mean that's number one that's
actually pretty dope especially like
a part of the the the writing staff i
mean
they did that stuff all the time like
when we were we would do a month of
wrestling training before every season
because we did all our own stunts
another reason
glow's the [ __ ] best thing ever and
um they oh hey glenn glenn says what's
up he's barking
um but another uh we would all these
crazy things would happen to us in
wrestling training
and they would write them into the
script that's so crazy
yeah they would just they would really
they were they would really listen to us
and hear what we were going through and
if they thought that it was powerful
narratively they would add it in
and glow was so incredible because
as i've mentioned probably at broken a
broken record number of times
having been in this business for as long
as i have i've never seen a show
up until glow i never auditioned for a
show where there was really like more
than one girl that had a chance to like
be funny or do
things yeah and if there were two girls
in it one was like a hot one and one was
the quirky friend
you know and it was like just very i
don't know
boring and always written by men who by
the way were brilliant writers but like
maybe not necessarily writing the female
play
yeah yeah yeah a woman could and then
glow comes along
and it gives 14 wild-ass
rodeo clown [ __ ] a chance to shine
and almost completely female writers and
almost completely female directors
and the show celebrating women of shapes
sizes colors i mean the show ages
women from their you know late teens to
their 40s and just really
celebrating women and i think that's a
major reason i mourn the show
and you know what's what was really cool
about the show tonight you mentioned
that it's like
i think one of my biggest criticisms now
is just because
a lot of you know this is a moving
business so when people
especially like in film or tv when
people try to capitalize off of movement
they tend to make things super campy
right they kind of shove it in your face
the great thing about collection yeah so
the great thing about glow was it's like
it might been the the overall impression
that you get is women empowerment but it
wasn't shoved in your face it just
is it's like like these women are
talented these women's of different
color shapes and sizes but it was never
put in your face right so you get to
just enjoy the show that's why the show
is so
[ __ ] good that's why i'm saying give
me
another [ __ ] season it needs to wrap
up
our god damn season four you know what's
crazy about that so
fully circle back to your first question
um
[Music]
we had a season four right so
we it was already happening we shot two
and a half episodes we
the sets were built obviously we were
working on them
all 10 scripts were written well let's
[ __ ] go
the cast was all in town from all over
the [ __ ] country and world and like
we were ready to go and then that nasty
dirty [ __ ] covet came to town
and they had to postpone us so we
started shooting glow
i mean it's so funny because when you
say this
here this time period like you can't the
listener can't help but groan
but we started shooting glow in march of
2020
and we started in february we probably
would have been far enough along
to fit but we were only two episodes in
and
you know they just logistically didn't
know when the world was reopening and
for the first six months of all of that
it was like
how is anything going to happen and then
once shows started to pick back up
they still were like how are we going to
do this particular one with 15
oh man each other and wrestling and it's
just
the show would end up taking much longer
because
we would shoot like 14-hour days but
with covet i think now there's like an
eight-hour
cap you'd have to get how much more
money it would cost for the constant
testing and the coveted officer
and all the lab techs and all the
whatever i mean and ultimately
they start crunching those numbers and i
guess it just didn't make sense
oh really ah damn i didn't know you guys
started shooting that because i just
heard
you were like my new character that we
bought
um debbie egan the betty gilpin the
blonde
she bought a tv network at the end of
season well whatever
watch the show but she this isn't too
spoilery she bought a tv
network also you'll never see this so i
can tell you
yeah so sad um and so we all had to have
new characters because
the vegas show that we were in in season
three
now owned our characters so we could oh
no rather
the tv show that we did in season two
they owned our characters
yeah so we're all gonna come back in
season four as completely new wrestling
characters
oh that would have been so [ __ ] dope
and i saw and so we got two episodes in
where we got to see
everybody in their new characters we
were training and wrestling and do
and the whole show was gonna was gonna
be
um incredible and brand new and i don't
wanna spoil too much because i mean i
guess we're still holding out hope to
make a movie but
oh please i just need something like
it's it's it's like i held in a sneeze
you know even me both that's that's what
it feels like it's and you know
netflix does such a great job in terms
of like when these new shows hit they
hit hard
so like when i when i was watching globe
you know during the time we were
shooting i was like dude look at the
production value on this [ __ ] is so
nuts it's so insane i mean
me aside i guess i i mean you can't it's
like my dad saying i'm the most talented
person in the world
and like dad you're my dad of course you
think that he's like no
have nothing to do with being your
father you are objectively the most
talented and it's like you don't
understand how objectivity works
but that's how i feel with glow i'm like
me aside
this is the best show ever what's
happening but i can't take me aside
obviously because it's
my show so of course i think that but
it's i'll tell you something i've
been on quite a few shows before that
and i don't
yeah like i it's one of those shows too
the production value's great the
cinematography
the writing the casting everything in it
it's damn near perfect
so it's crazy it's it's crazy how well
you guys work together too like cast
chemistry
is really good on that show and i think
that's like the hard part to find in a
lot of these shows it's like you can
have
sometimes some really great actors and
actresses but if the chemistry is not
there it's not there but you guys
meld really well together it's like it's
almost like watching like a docu-series
like that's what it feels like to me
well do you know that glow is based on
an actual 80s tv show called the
gorgeous ladies of wrestling
oh really oh i just blew your mind so no
i didn't know that
so our show is a fictionalized version
a scripted fictionalized version of a
real thing that happened
that's [ __ ] nuts so these women these
actresses and athletes
they sort of showed up just like we do
in season one and they were like what
the [ __ ] is this or am i
and some shitty guy comes out like marin
comes out he's like
hello ladies welcome to the gorgeous
ladies of wrestling now if any of you
don't want to beat the [ __ ] out of each
other now be a good time to leave
and then half of them leave and then
this and then these women in the 80s oh
you should have you have to look up
the documentary of glo which is
the documentary of the original gorgeous
ladies of wrestling
so our show runners liz and carly and
genji cohan
they got the rights to that 80s kitschy
campy ass show and
made the scripted version oh see that
explains so much
because it feels that's why it feels
docu vibes yeah yeah yeah yeah
how crazy and that initial show
was so ahead of its time because it was
first of all
women central women that is wrestling
for crying out loud
rare especially in the 80s then it was
women being athletic and then it was
the first time women were wrestling also
the show was sketch as well so in
between their wrestling thing
right their wrestling uh matches rather
they would cut to you know
the farmer's daughter and whatever and
one of the other girls
and they would be like literally doing a
comedy sketch and then they would cut
back to a wrestling match then they
would cut to like all the girls doing a
musical number
wow it was wackadoo that's crazy
and so our show was the scripted version
of that
that's insane i definitely have to watch
that doc like
i mean well get ready to cry but yes oh
no i'm gonna
it's incredible i mean it's an emotional
journey they do an amazing job i'm sorry
this pandemic i've watched so many
things that make me cry it's like damn
dude like what's going on what's with
the
waterworks i'm constantly texting people
like they'll send me something sweet or
whatever and i'm like hey just crying
like i just let me ask you something the
tears are so ready
right now one of the funniest bits that
i actually
it's very i think it's very uh uncommon
there's a lot of times when i watch show
where something's funny like i'm
like laughing but there was a there was
a scene that you're in that had me
[ __ ]
dying laughing this joke cracked me the
[ __ ] up it was when you were in
the the hotel and you're trying to pick
up this dude
and then it turns out
yo when that scene came up i was so
blindsided by that joke
i [ __ ] started crying laughing i was
like
when should we spoil or no this spoiled
it is okay it's been out for a while
when he thinks when i thought
that he thought i was a prostitute
yeah he starts laughing in my face he's
like wait a minute
you thought i thought you were a pro no
he's like i'm a
dude you need to pay me and i'm like
no it's so devastating i don't think i
explained it
when i watched that scene i was like
that's the moment when i look i'm like i
wish i would have wrote that joke
correct when i read the script my mouth
dropped my mouth dropped
also i will add that it was my idea they
were because obviously like i had to be
naked in that yeah really scared and we
had all these like sensitivity training
beforehand
and all that we have to go to through
crazy things in 2020 or whenever we shot
that 2019
to be naked on tv with another person
yeah
men and women both he and i needed to
sit together with a sensitivity trainer
and talk about like how our parts were
going to be covered so they wouldn't be
touching
and then they come in with they have a
thing called are you ready for this
they have a thing called the vajoga
which is a yoga mat
cut into the shape of like a bikini
bottom
that you put in between your legs to
cover your vag
so that when he's when he's pounding you
you are you have a yoga mat thickness
between you
so there's like no contact
on top of that of a yoga i've never
talked about this
on top of that i have on
what's called a whale tail which is a
thong
that tapes like right above your bush
and then it goes through your legs and
tapes right at the base of your
right the tip of your ass crack so it's
covering your parts
but you could stand there and look
almost completely naked
so then they do so first i'm sorry so
first they put on
first they moleskin
me shut they put moleskin
that you know what that is like that
yeah yeah sort of flesh colored but
maybe like
felt sticker over me
on my area to cover it then they put on
the whale tail
so i'm completely covered and
then they put a vajoga between my legs
and then he's doing the same thing he's
covering up all his parts
he doesn't get the yoga and then we put
our bodies together
so it's interesting like there's nothing
in the planet
less sexy so it's one of those things
like when you're in a relationship and
your partner's like oh my god
you had to [ __ ] do it on tv like
that's obviously would be very hard for
anyone's partner like
yeah would look that intimate with
someone else yeah
it could not be less intimate or less
sexy all you have to say is hey
the joker the joke about it okay okay i
get it yeah yeah granted
perfect and then they call cut and
people run in with like
robes and then you're cold and you've
got like all goose bumps and [ __ ] and
it's just like
it's awkward and you're standing there
but all that said
they were like you know you can put your
shirt back on for when you guys start
fighting and i'm like it's way funnier
to fight with my tits out
so um the the comic in me
beat out the insecure lady that was like
oh my god yes give me my clothes back as
soon as humanly possible
i was like nah fighting with titties out
is just too funny i'll keep my shirt off
and they were like are you sure and i
was like that's funny it's like we're
already in this let's let's 100
let's go we're already here fell to the
ground let's just do it
that was that your first uh topless
scene it was my first video for sure
um yes it was my first it was my first
anything
of that of that regard um and it was it
was wild
but you know ally and betty and had been
i mean the show is so
tasteful there is i don't think there's
zero there's any nudity on that show
that's not just like
perfectly done and classy and beautiful
and adds to the scene and is like funny
and necessary
it's not like everyone on glow is
walking around banging out naked and
you know like it's women in a dressing
room so if someone is meeting with her
back then someone else comes in and she
isn't fully dressed yet
she turns around you'll maybe see some
boob like it's just
it was more important to us to create
a space a real true
safe space for women yeah and if it was
like
you know certain times you're like okay
that was a little extra not on glow on
other things you're watching you're like
okay that's just sex for sex
for the purpose of sex and it's oh you
talking about a game of thrones
yeah like it always it always like it
kind of i mean it's hot a lot of the
time but it
it like reeks you're like yeah i can see
what you're doing here yeah yeah
that way anglo it was always like
not to again here i go with my feminist
flag but like it was always
female positivity and body positivity
and power
first yeah a hundred percent and
you feel that when you're watching it
because i was on such a special show i
was like you know what
i'm kind of happy doing this um really
funny story actually
i don't know if they'll love me telling
this but it's a it's a glow classic
um i was really nervous
about being topless
and so uh i get a knock on my trailer
door
and uh it's ali and betty and they put
their coats on and they're all dressed
and i was like
hey you guys and um they were like
we heard you're nervous and i was like i
really am and they both
let their coats drop and they just had
their tits out
and they were just talking to me and
they were like hey dude so they're
standing there with their so they're
like
so we just heard you were nervous and we
wanted to know if there was like
anything we could do to like help you
out or make you feel like
it's something to be more okay with and
i was cr
hysterical cry laughing because they
just they just and then they committed
the whole time and they were like so if
there's like you know truly
honestly jack seriously like we know you
are like freaking out like
truly let us know and i'm like i'm just
looking at your cans get out of here
and then i went to set and i did it and
it was just really
yo girls are so funny like i remember
like my my one of my friends she just
got uh implants for the first time
right this is years ago and you know
like as guys
we don't know how comfortable women are
with each other right it's not like a
guy just walks out and whips out his
dick and he's just like hey
what's going on yeah you know here's my
balls back
but but literally this girl just got her
implants and you know she just rested up
it's all fine now
and then they're all hanging out and
they're like oh we want to see let's go
to the bathroom
they just walk into the bathroom and you
can hear them talking like
whoa those are really nice like can i
touch it look good those look real can i
touch them
i'm like is this what girls do like well
i'll tell you
with natural boobs we we definitely
don't just show each other our tits for
no reason yeah yeah yeah
but i do have a friend who recently got
hers done and we were in another
friend's kitchen actually
it's funny when you say recently because
then you do the math and you're like
well that was before the pandemic so
that's a
long ago yeah um anyway last week era
though
we were just in a friend's kitchen and
she just lifted her shirt she was like
yeah we were all like oh my god
gorgeous that looks great people were
touching
and it was like 100 but with like
natural boobs we're not going i mean we
see each other's boobs generally and
change in front of each other but it's
not
you know no one's whipping them out to
be like take a look at these
yeah because i know like so when we were
in when i went to japan they had like
these
these uh saunas right and you're
supposed to be butt naked in there
like korean and japanese people like
when it comes to like being nude in
front of somebody it's not that big of a
deal
especially when you go to these saunas
like you go to these korean saunas in
k-town
you're all everything's out i go i go to
the korean spa
right like it is what it is right but
then and i love it
afterwards too like my fiance is so
funny uh she comes out after we i'm in
the guideline and she's in the girls
ones and then we come out
we're hanging out in our hotel room she
goes you know
nipples are all different i was like
what did you mean dude she's like yeah
like everybody's is just a little
different
it's like a little snowflake you know
they're so unique
oh that's the cutest thing ever it makes
me bite my teeth
really it really is true and it's like
that's another thing about glow
it's like everybody's boo everyone who
showed their boobs and like
you really get to see because i think as
a little girl growing up the only boobs
i saw on tv
were either fake ones or were like what
men
what we've been told are perfect boobs
they're perky they're round the nipples
are the right size and it's like it's
exhausting
it is exhaust i mean it's wonderful to
be a woman but it's exhausting the
uh emotional warfare we wage on both
ourselves and
is waged on us to be like oh that's what
our
that's what my tits have to look exactly
like for me to like myself or like them
or want to show anybody them
without it being in the dark like
this is what we're taught well this is
what i say
like all these dudes who who do say that
i've said this on this podcast before
any guy that
go when they look at a boob that's not
like their ideal boob and they go
because you're a [ __ ] virgin like
you've never like you've never [ __ ]
seen a woman naked before
like shut the [ __ ] up like all that
shit's different dude the [ __ ] are you
talking about bro
yeah also the men who say that
i would like that i would like a 8x10
glossy of their [ __ ] and balls
sent directly to my house for me to
judge
because you don't get to judge like and
that's the other thing like we were
talking about with women
with women and men like as men get older
they're sexier as women get older they
expire
like women i mean from
i've been one for a long time we don't
like dick size isn't even really like a
thing it's like no one even cares it's
like
unless it's micro but other than that
nobody cares and like it's such a man
thing and i think even with a lot of
dudes too like
it's pretty [ __ ] woke of you to be
like
you're an idiot but because i think a
lot of men feel like to be
funny and cool and included they need to
like agree with
homeboy who says oh those tits are gross
or whatever and it's like you should by
the way you should be so lucky she
wouldn't come within
she wouldn't touch you with a 10-foot
pole anyway friend well that's what i'm
saying it's like
like i would always hear this
conversation about dudes and you know
for me it was just obnoxious
because like you know you would see a
guy like they look
like the most disgusting [ __ ]
creature you've ever seen in your
[ __ ] life
like like a bar of soap hasn't touched
their body ever
and they see this girl walk by and they
go oh you don't know what i would do
with that it's like no you wouldn't know
what to do with that yeah you wouldn't
because that woman would never approach
you you were near her she would start
running because she could smell you
already from a mile away
so the first thing you'd have to do is
take up
jogging behind her so you can lose the
rest of the narrative about how you'd
bend her over the couch
because [ __ ] is nowhere near you
exactly that's why it was just the
oddest thing like
i would hear this and it was just
obnoxious it's like why do you do who
taught you this
like if you wouldn't approach her and
talk to her then you shouldn't say that
type of [ __ ]
in the first place it's just like this
weird thing like i even talk about this
word
uh you know what you see on on instagram
like some girls they'll post their
pictures and let's say they don't
photoshop it you see stretch marks and
they're like
uh she asked i was like dude every
[ __ ] girl has stretch marks what the
[ __ ] are you talking about that's a
massive problem on both sides
right because magazines photoshop
everything
now we have the ability when we're
posting
everything is filters and photoshop and
smoothing and face tune
i mean i it's really hard and because of
that
men see women who look flawless and then
so women and men both see women who look
flawless
and judge themselves against that and
it's a false reality
so women are like oh my god look at her
amazing skin it's like yeah just go like
that on face tune and make yours look
like that
i mean i don't choose to do that but
that's how people
do it so it's like we are comparing
ourselves
to a fake not expectation but
yeah like i had this conversation about
like uh recently too
about you know how popularized cosmetic
surgery is now right
and i think i feel like the narrative
has changed a lot from when it was
before it was
find everything about you that's
beautiful and then appreciate that
and now it's look i have the money i
could change whatever the [ __ ] i want
and that's real women empowerment so
like i don't i don't
when i heard that like it always sat
funny with me right because
when i when i see somebody try to change
something physical about themselves it's
very fleeting
like your looks are going to change it's
going to fade over time it doesn't
[ __ ] matter
like yeah you should try to look your
best while you have what you got that's
fine
but once it goes away it goes away for a
reason you can age with grace
and i've always had this weird
conversation now especially like in this
city
because i don't have this conversation
back at home in sacramento i don't have
it in these smaller cities and towns but
these huge metropolitan cities there's
this idea that you should just change
whatever the [ __ ] it is you want about
your face
and they think that it's going to fix
something in my personal opinion i have
yet to see
where that change becomes permanent
right where they change
i've also yet to see with very few
exceptions
like for example my friend who just got
her boobs done it truly made her happier
yeah he was flat her whole life she
really wanted boobs and it was like
awesome god bless
but like if you're born looking facially
looking one way
and you spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars to change
every single thing about your face i'm
here for that if you want to do that
i think what i'm not here for is our
deifying and then idolizing what that
person looks like
like yeah well you could look like that
if you spend the money like
for me if we want to be like oh my god
giselle is flawless well she was born
that way she's genuinely flawless
i think it's more confusing for me when
we and not that i think we should
idolize her because she's a beautiful
woman
i'm just saying i think it's easier for
my brain to for me to wrap my brain
around
like we're well i think we're in this
weird space
of idolizing people who spent a ton of
money to change what they look like yeah
yeah and i think it's fine if you want
to change what you look like
that's okay i don't want to do that if
you want to do that that's okay
i think it's the idolizing and how much
it's making
young girls and women feel shitty about
themselves
because they don't look like that yeah
well that person doesn't look like that
either
yeah 100 that's
that's i think the part that is is hard
and also
it's you know and then men their
standards are going to this weird false
place that's not a reality
yeah girls standards are going like
that's not real what you're looking at
well yeah and this is what i said too
like on my last podcast it's like these
dudes also say
and i gotta check some of these guys all
the time it's like yo
you keep putting up these posts and
stories saying like oh these girls are
doing too much with their lips and all
this other stuff
i like girls without makeup but
[ __ ] who are the girls you're
following on instagram they don't look
like that
yep so you're a [ __ ] hypocrite like
you're
jacking off and you're [ __ ] correct
bookmarking these [ __ ] girls that
you're criticizing so who are you to say
anything you're also setting this
odd standard so at the same time like
for me i just like
people to look different i think like
the difference is what makes because
there's like a
everybody [ __ ] with something different
right because when everybody starts to
look the same which i see a lot it's
like
i i just i don't like that it's weird
sometimes i find myself
zooming in on someone's face trying to
figure out what i'm even looking at
and it's so pretty but i'm like what
shape lips is
i'm like cricking my neck to try and
figure out like now there's a thing
where people get like their eyes
pulled up like they get it's like sort
of a
eye facelift and like it's creeps me out
man i know they just looked at my eyes
and they're like i want those it's like
nah bro these are here dude
i don't even have to do this
[ __ ] this is how i am
baby i was born this way
you know i didn't threads they get a
thread
put through here into their scalp
nothing and you know the
the concept of beauty too the standard
always changes so what's the point
that's true too i remember um
i had friends years ago who were all
getting their bushes completely lasered
off
and i was like you're gonna want hair
there at some point
it's gonna come back believe me well it
doesn't come back
when it's lasered off it's gone i mean
for at least five or ten years
yeah so like i did my pits because i'm
like there is no universe i'm ever gonna
want pit hair i'm good
yeah but i knew people that did their
whole bush and you were like yo
what that [ __ ] changes or eyebrows
people who lasered off their eyebrows
and now big old thick eyebrows are back
it's like
well that was a snake you tweezed them
all out and made them into a weird line
let me tell you something the 90s
eyebrows were [ __ ] crazy
like the eyebrows look like the 90s the
liner were nice
boys it was the [ __ ] line you know
what i mean and that [ __ ] was
was the [ __ ] back like girls were
shaving their brows off i
have friends who tweezed their eyebrows
so hard in college that they didn't grow
back
i had a makeup artist do me for
something the other day
and um she was like she's thinking about
getting uh what's it called like
hair transplant surgery or something
like how men do it
oh yeah yeah yeah i know what you're
talking about yeah i'm gonna do it for
her eyebrows
i didn't know that was a possibility oh
everything's a possibility
it's crazy eyebrows to make the face
though like when somebody has a [ __ ]
eyebrow
eyebrows are important but like people
tattoo them
but it's like it has to be hair how's a
tattoo going to do that you can tell
it's not hair
yeah they do the uh microblading thing
right where they uh they microblade it
and they
and they uh it makes it look like it's a
lot fuller yeah
like right here my parents my parents
know the beauty supply store so i always
noticed like these weird things like
with eyebrows and [ __ ] but i remember
the trend of eyebrows you know your
parents owned a beauty supply store
yeah they still do sacramento in
sacramento so we own a black beauty
supply store so i grew up in like a
predominantly black neighborhood
this is a very good piece of information
yeah this is i love to learn that [ __ ]
yeah so like hair eyebrows makeup was
something that i was just always around
like there was like a nail shop right
next to it yeah so that's what i was
doing my whole life which is observing
hair
i'm just like look at this that bitch's
hair and now i love you even more a
little baby david so just being like so
that's what a weave is
yo in high school i used to just start
braiding girl's hair up in class i would
just like straight start braiding their
hair like this
oh you were you getting very laid were
you just no i was
i was not getting laid at all i just
like hair i was like girl you just sit
there
let me do your hair real quick i'll just
be braiding girl's hair i'm going to be
doing your personality now but i'm a 17
year old who's like
creating a hot black girl's hair and i'm
like oh wow this is very exciting
like baby stay still hold on a second
maybe stay still you know this is what i
would do
now like high school for me i was i only
had like one crush like i only liked one
girl in high school and i was very
[ __ ] awkward like i started
you know growing into my personality and
my skin when i like after high school
huh right so it was like probably toward
my senior year of high school i was like
hey you know what [ __ ] all this stuff
i'm just gonna be myself
you know oh my goodness well that was a
good idea yeah i mean
and then it was listen and then it was
just years and years of basketball
shorts until now
you know what the basketball shorts
started happening when i was really
started getting into stand-up comedy
because i was like
if i'm gonna be a stand-up what the [ __ ]
doesn't matter what i look like
just be funny wear whatever the [ __ ] you
want and they don't like it it doesn't
matter what you look like you're just
supposed to stand up for women is like
you can't wear something too sexy
because then the people in the audience
are looking at
your body and your knockers instead of
your comedy
but then you also don't want to be too
much of a dump because
you wanna it's just like it's such this
is such a it's such a funny business
that's so hard to deal with it's like
why can't i just be [ __ ] funny why
can't i just
act like why does everything else have
to entail this one part when you should
really be looking at the skill
that's the hard part it is it really is
and it's like it's
so many things are considered and come
into play
it's it's you know it's funny for me
because um
i really did not i mean i won't say i
failed because i had a lot of close
calls and
um but i mean i had some like crazy
you know made twelve thousand dollars in
a year years
but this business is
and it's funny because i can look back
on it now with a little bit of
a sense of clarity sitting in the
body in space and success that i'm
currently today sitting in
which of course i'm hyper aware that
could knock on would-be gun at any
moment
as it was and to go back
to where i was for so long i mean i
i recognize how lucky i am but it it's
still
it's such it this is a heartbreaking
business ever like pretty much daily
when i got
um leftovers actually so first i met the
magical elves then we all went over to
netflix
to see if they felt similarly about me
that the elves did
as the elves did rather and then
the first time this ever happened to me
in my life i don't know if you know this
where i was waiting in
outside with uh with casey and joe and
think sam from the elves outside the
netflix building after the meeting
and toby the head of the magical elves
at the time came out of the net we were
like i was like where's toby and they
were like oh
he's still talking to netflix and he
came outside of the netflix building and
he said
well it's you they love you they want to
they want to move forward with you and
ice
burst into tears really
first i'm crying i'm getting emotional
right now i was like
what no no they did they did not today
tell me they said that if you
they better [ __ ] said that if you're
saying i was crying and he was like
it's okay it's okay and i was like wait
what if it all and
what came out of my mouth for
immediately was what if it all falls
apart
wow and he said it might
but you haven't it was great he goes i
don't know what's going to happen from
here
and we'll and he will he what he said in
a cute way
he goes at night he goes obviously you
know contingent on deals working out and
all that stuff
but it's you we want you they want you
and it was like 20 it was like
31 years of
waiting for someone to say that and mean
it
do you have like this uh feeling of
imposter syndrome sometimes like when
you have
like your level of success because
nobody knows your personal struggle like
starting as an actor like a childhood
actor
to getting your hit at 36. you know well
i actually don't have imposter syndrome
it's one of the
few psychological issues associated with
being an actor that i don't suffer from
so uh i suffered from
guilt when i wasn't working that i was
not happy for my friends who were
working because it was so hard to
celebrate everybody else's
seeming constant success in the face of
my constant failure
yeah um so i always suffered from that
was a hard one for me to get over just
like
their success doesn't mean my failure i
mean my failure means my failure yeah
um only suffer from that but something
in me whether that's like my internal
combustion engine or just how i feel
about myself or what my parents
instilled in me
i never had imposter syndrome i have
always
consistently felt like i can
[ __ ] do this can somebody let me
and the time and when i started
succeeding it wasn't
it was because somebody let me but it
was also because i finally let myself
i wasn't just sitting there with reps
waiting for the phone to ring and that's
okay if people want to
be an actor and do that that wasn't
working for me so i really started doing
more stand up i started touring
i started making my own stuff i started
writing and this way now when i was
going on auditions
my whole universe wasn't wrapped up and
whether i was or was not going to get
this single episode of um
[ __ ] blue bloods like
i had a bigger story at that point i was
touring i was opening for cool people
i was doing my jokes i was feeling good
managers were
starting to be like oh you're funny and
i was like oh so all i had to do
was do it um
and i mean not that it was like one two
three easy once i started doing stand up
i mean
even then i i started saying it when i
was 14 and then in my 20s i stopped
because
i was afraid of my own shadow and really
dove into the relationships i was
instead of focusing on myself
but then back in my when i was like 30
or 31 i started doing stand-up but
consistently
and still it was five years later until
i got close so it wasn't like that
happened immediately either
but it was there was a there was a
change in me that i was ready to focus
on myself
um as much or more than the
relationships that i was in and
sort of cultivating the men that i was
with to be
the best they could be i think that
attitude's so important too especially
what you said that's so
it's like well like i have what it takes
i just need someone to allow me to do it
you know that's such a powerless
feeling because then you're like
there's literally nothing i could do to
make myself succeed i have to just
i have to just wait for some like that's
insane
yeah i mean i think that's what i kind
of felt you know
like the first time i got booked
something and then
i didn't get it was because like the
character got
cut out i think that [ __ ] was hard right
it was like oh
i went through all these [ __ ] hoops
they love me and they're like hey we're
just gonna this character doesn't work
here so we're gonna leave it out
that that [ __ ] hurt like i didn't you
know because i've been i'm pretty much
scabbed over i think like when i first
started auditioning my very first
audition
i bombed terribly and i think i i
remember i went into my car
and i laid the seat back and i went you
[ __ ] did
it i just sat there like what the [ __ ]
i called my baby i called one of them
i did because i just wanted to die in my
car and i just called my
i wanted to yell toward the roof as
opposed to the windshield
i wanted to echo back into my [ __ ]
stupid face
and so i called my friend who was an
active buddy i was like hey bro i bombed
that [ __ ] i was like is this how you
feel he goes yeah just get used to it
and then
you'll scab over and then the next one i
did scab over i was like well that's
about the worst audition i could ever
have in mind
you know you scabbed over right away
though
i think i just i just didn't want to
feel a lot of people years and then
they're just you know
i had a big i had a big uh
period of my life in my which is really
weird i did a play in new york and when
i came back to la
i um i was getting i was so
nervous on auditions that my hands and
feet were shaking
wow i couldn't i couldn't now i didn't
feel nervous i wasn't like but my
body was nervous i couldn't
like i couldn't i couldn't take it it's
crazy i mean you've been doing it for so
long i mean before we sign off
um what is like some advice that you
would give to somebody who wants to go
into acting glenn do you want to come
say hi to david while i before we sign
off come here i want to see glenn
come here because you have to speak to
david it's so
a famous man come here little puppy
that's right yo your dog's face is hard
my name is glenn my heart is full
i am the worst wondrous man my arms are
sticks
don't take a look my heart is too big
and i'm doing licks
your dog looks like he could give a [ __ ]
less like
what is this never met a more zen [ __ ]
glenn is just like no matter where you
hold him or put him he's just like
he's the chillest man that ever was like
he's a perfect dog for me he like
just absorbs my neuroses and is like hmm
he's great i thought when you look i
would say my advice
ties into what we were just talking
about
which is you if you want to do this
um i mean a million things have to
happen but
i i truly think the most important one
is that you have to create your own
stuff you know you have to
i think that like the days of just like
being an actor
like that's incredible but it's really
this business is so saturated especially
with like
you know the i guess advent is not quite
the right word but like
with tick tock and instagram and people
getting famous through social media all
the time
i mean some of these massive companies
are like you know lauding
the the new people they sign and they're
like you know
and a few years ago it was vine stars
and then it was instastars and now it's
tick-tock stars and like
and i'm not saying that is a bad thing
i'm saying like so if that's not your
jam like you need to
figure out especially in the pandemic
it's hard it's not like you can go do
stand up because for me that's what
changed my life
instead of me because it changed my mind
right so instead of waiting for someone
to say jackie
you're enough you're okay you're funny
you got the job i said no
i'm just gonna go do something
i'm gonna it changes it from being
passive to being active
it changes it from mentally you waiting
and being sad and feeling like you're
not chosen
did you choosing your [ __ ] self and
getting on stage
and failing a ton but meeting cool
people and punching up each other's
jokes
in like the bathroom at the comedy i
mean the
improv and like it changes the whole
energy and it just makes you feel
so much more alive than just being like
boy i hope i get that secret
deodorant commercial call back otherwise
i'll get my insurance or pay my rent or
have any self-respect
and so it's it's hard you know um
and so i think the number one advice i
could give is like
just truly do
i mean you but make things and if make
things means to you
writing you love to write and you you
know and you
submit your writing to get sort of funny
editorials advice or cosmo
or just do things yeah just to stay
active i think that's very important and
you know i think like the biggest the
biggest difference that i see from
you know a lot of younger people who
want to go into the traditional acting
space be in movies and films and they
you know you guys want to do it through
youtube and
everything else but the hard part is now
that everybody's social interaction
is with themselves were they talking to
a camera like the
the i think the the greatest thing about
you is like your life experience
makes up so much of your personality who
you are like how you speak in the camera
everything all that other stuff a lot of
these people are lacking because
they don't talk to people they don't
have conversations they're not
experiencing new things so
a lot of the times when it comes to like
i can ask you a question and you know
what to say because you're confident
because of the life experiences that
you've had
and so a lot of these kids and i think
that also transfers over the screen
like you don't have life experiences you
have very limited things that you can
draw from
you know and i think because of you when
i when i meet you and then
when we were doing the chem test that i
didn't know was a chem test it's like oh
this girl is [ __ ]
hilarious i felt the same way and then
you left and everyone was like so him
right like it was great
that's dope i had no idea i was just
like everyone was like so him and we
were like i was like well yeah
let's see let's see who else we like is
here
and then we saw rosemary and we were all
like
well she's nuts let's do it
i mean and also so funny about rosemary
because like she might be the only
person that talks more than me
and we were on a zoom trying to do a
chem test as we were on a zoom
there was also a lag and so it's like
two people that
never shut up but also a lag so like no
one knew when someone was taking a break
when to start when to go
so it's hard to actually see if there
was going to be chemistry because
we are both such big personalities and
it was over zoom
yeah i think we ended up just getting so
crazy lucky with her with how lovely she
ended up being and how funny she ended
up being
and knowledgeable and it all just um
it was worked out it was so fun like
being on set was
was fun i was like yo this is unlikely
trio
rojaxo row jackson baby for life
well jackie thank you for hopping on in
that was super enlightening
i'm i'm i'm inspired every time i'm
inspired i absolutely i just adore you
um i used to kind of gag when people
said that word but i'm also like that's
just how i feel so i don't know
that's that's that's you girl you're
you're an inspiring person like your
energy is so [ __ ] dope like i've
there's very few people that i get to
meet where i'm just like this person can
do anything the [ __ ] that they want
and that's like the vibe that i get the
same way about you and i think in season
if we get a season two
if you think that we're not both singing
songs then i don't know
i just think it's so it's so sickening
that i had to learn that you had like
john legend level skills after we
wrapped i was like is this kind of
[ __ ] what's wrong with this kid
no no no no no i i get nervous when i
sing them like
like i don't care i don't have time
honestly like i'm trying to care about
you i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care about your feelings i just
care about how you sound when you sing
and i want to hear it so that's all i'm
saying hey we'll we'll make it happen on
the second scene
it's going to happen i believe it i
believe it right here you need it i need
it i need it
i can't wait i can't wait wait okay babe
love you very much to thank you for
having me
yes okay bye